bonjour à tous euh moi à la base j'avais
absolument pas vocation à venir vous
parler aujourd'hui du futur du sport et
de l'innovation dans le sport euh comme
cela vient d'être dit j'avais travaillé
pendant 2 ans en cabinet ministériel
j'étais chef adjoint du cabinet de la
ministre des Sports de 2012 2014 en
charge des relations internationales en
charge de la lutte contre le dopage des
sujets un peu éloignés de l'innovation
et du changement en tant que tel mon
problème c'était plutôt la résistance au
changement des institutions que le
changement et qu'être moteur du
changement en tant que tel le changement
c'était pas vraiment maintenant et euh
et quand après le remanement de de
2014 bah comme beaucoup de conseil
ministériel j'ai redécouvert les les
belles couleurs de mon appartement que
je n'avais pas vu pendant un moment j'ai
su et j'ai appris très rapidement que la
mairie de Paris lançait ce projet de
plateforme d'innovation pour le sport et
euh c'est avec euh grand plaisir que je
l'ai rejoint quand il ils me l'ont
proposé il fallait quand même que je
comprenne et que je sache pourquoi euh
ils avaient décidé de créer une
plateforme d'innovation pour le sport
alors en fait le premier projet de
plateforme d'innovation euh n'avait pas
été fait dans le sport c'était une
plateforme d'innovation dédié au
tourisme qui existe et qui s'appelle Le
Welcome City Lab la mairie de Paris
avait décidé de créer SWC City Lab
notamment suite à un classement un
classement TripAdvisor de la qualité
d'accueil des grandes villes du monde où
Paris arrivver au-delà de la 20e place
ça vous étonnera pas plus que ça quand
on connaît la qualité d'accueil de nos
chauffeurs de taxis des réceptionnistes
dans les hôtels quand on connaît le
bilinguisme naturel des brasseurs
parisiens bref il y avait un problème ce
problème le problème c'est que les
industriels du secteur touristique et
l'économie touristique ne le voyit pas
il ne le voyit pas parce que ça marchait
bien pour eux ça marche toujours bien
pour eux néanmoins si on se pose
quelques questions sur l'hôtellerie par
exemple sans s'en apercevoir les
hôteliers bah ont perdu 15 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires qui partent
directement à San Francisco via booking
et qu'aujourd'hui c'est 15 % ils ne les
récupéreront pas donc il y avait eu la
décision de créer cette plateforme
d'innovation sur le tourisme
c'est-à-dire de même dans un de mettre
dans un même lieu des start-ups des
grands groupes des partenaires
institutionnels et essayer de faire
bouillonner tout cela pour inventer le
tourisme de demain les motivations pour
créer une plateforme d'innovation pour
le sport étaiit différentes il y en
avait principalement trois la première
c'était que le sport c'est un secteur
qui était porteur porteur en terme
économique porteur en terme
d'emploi et que ce secteur il avait
vocation à accueillir beaucoup
d'innovation il y avait de maintes et
maines innovations dans le sport et
qu'en plus il n'était pas structuré il
n'était pas structuré pour les
accueillir aujourd'hui elle vient d'être
créée mais il n'existait pas de filière
économique du sport il y avait une
multiplicité d'acteurs autour de
l'économie du sport nous on avait pas
vocation à prendre cette place et à
créer cette filière mais en tout cas
regrouper ses acteurs autour de la
thématique du sport et de
l'innovation moi je suis arrivé à ce
moment-là volonté de changement volonté
de changer j'ai tout de suite dit oui
mais avec ces grands principes j'étais
pas très avancé
encore du coup je connaissais rien au
start-up du sport j'en connaissais peu
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je
connaissais plus des acteurs
institutionnel du sport la résistance au
changement que la volonté de changement
et du coup qu'est-ce que j'ai fait j'ai
rencontré j'ai rencontré quelques
personnes et j'ai notamment dès le
deuxème jour de ma mission rencontré
Bertrand Picard Bertrand Picard c'est un
entrepreneur qui a monter sa boîte il y
a 4 ans il
était financier à la City il travaillait
chez rthchiild et il a dû un jour
travailler sur le modèle économique des
stades il a dû travailler un jour sur le
modèle économique des stad et il s'est
dit il y a un problème il y a un
problème pucequeun stade ne peut être
rentable que si on fait plusieurs
événements par semaine dans ce stade or
Arsen Wenger ne veut pas qu'on joue sur
sa pelouse hors match d'Arsenal il veut
pas parce que ça l'abîme et même quand
l'Angleterre accueille la Coupe du monde
de rugby bah l'émirat Stadium n'est pas
mis à disposition de la Coupe du monde
de rugby parce que Arsen Wenger ne veut
pas qu'on joue rugby dans son stade donc
le problème c'était pas le fait qu'on
puisse avoir nombre d'événement dans les
stades c'était la pelouse c'était la
pelouse et Bertrand Picard du coup il a
inventé une nouvelle pelouse une pelouse
naturelle parce que la pelouse
cnthétique ça tapppit pas non plus aux
entraîneurs ni aux joueurs mais sur
substrat semiynthétique cette pelouse il
a mis plus de 2 ans à la créer
aujourd'hui il équipe 5 des 10 stads de
l'Euro 2016 et il va équiper l'année
prochaine Arsenal comme il le dit
lui-même pour un Français vendre de la
pelouse aux anglais ça fait plaisir moi
face à cette rencontre je me suis dit ça
va il y a quelqu'un qui connaît
absolument rien au sport qui vient de la
City et qui s'est dit il y a un secteur
économique à creuser et donc je me suis
tout de suite dit en fait les start-up
du sport on les connaî peut-être pas
mais il doit en avoir beaucoup et cette
cet aspect là m'a encouragé à aller de
l'avant j'ai rencontré aussi très vite
des acteurs du sport des acteurs
industriels et des acteurs
institutionnels notamment l'INSEP
l'INSEP c'est l'Institut National du
Sport de l'expertise et de la
performance et je me suis aperçu que
pour eux la démarche d'innovation était
essentielle et que la Proxim avec les
startup était ultra importante donc ça
m'a convaincu aussi du fait que les
acteurs institutionnels du sport
pouvaient facilement être convaincu de
la nécessité et de l'importance de créer
une plateforme d'innovation pour le
sport du coup cette plateforme
d'innovation pour le sport on l'a créé
on l'a créé depuis maintenant un peu
plus d'un an avec quatre métiers quatre
métiers principaux le métier
d'incubation on a incubé pendant un an
maintenant 17 start-up on va en incuber
30 demain un métier de de mise en
relation avec tes partenaires et de
faire venir des partenaires dans cette
plateforme un métier d'animation De Mul
de multiplier des animations des
conférences des atelier sur la
problématique du sport et de
l'innovation et un métier de
communication et de veille qui est
extrêmement
important pour nous ça a pas été facile
ça a pas été facile parce qu'il fallait
convaincre les start-up du sport qui ne
nous connaissaient pas forcément au
départ de venir dans notre incubateur il
fallait les convaincre qu'en étant
ensemble elles serait plus forte
qu'individuellement travailler sur les
synergies entre start-up alors qu' il
avaient un peu peur de perdre leur
secret et de perdre leur identité mais
finalement aujourd'hui on a un Modelle
qui fonctionne like motif pendant toute
cette toute cette construction ça a été
cette phrase de Churchill j'ai un peu
l'esprit de contradiction donc j'aime
bien citer celui qui avait fait d'e no
sport le secret de sa longévité et cette
phrase pour moi elle est très importante
m mieux vaut prendre le changement par
la main avant qu'il ne nous prenne par
la gorge pas besoin de faire une une
longue une longue exégèse de cette
phrase c'est assez simple le changement
si on le prend avec soi si on en fait
tout simplement un ami un accompagnement
il va nous permettre d'apporter beaucoup
de choses si on se met à dos et si on le
voit avec avec un regard distant au
contraire c'est lui qui va nous agresser
euh aujourd'hui je vais vous parler du
futur du sport du futur du sport par les
start-up très clairement les forces
vives du trempelin de cet incubateur
qu'on a créé ce sont les start-ups ce
sont eux qui ont cré les projets ce sont
eux qui ont créé les projets les plus
forts du coup je vais je vais vous
parler de leur projet en tant que tel je
vais pas vous faire de la prospective à
2025 ou la prospective à 2020 je vais
vous je vais vous parler de projets
concrets qui existent
aujourd'hui alors moi quand j'ai
commencé à voir ces nombreux projets ces
nombreux start-up du sport j'avais une
conviction la conviction c'était que le
modèle du sport était en train de
changer et qu'il a fondamentalement un
modèle qui é en train de changer c'est
celui du club aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
me disais les pratiquants de Sport le
club ça les ennuie parce qu'il y a des
horaires parce qu'il y a des contraintes
de lieux ils ont envie d'une pratique
complètement libre et complètement
indépendante et j'ai été relativement
surpris surpris en bien que un certain
nombre de start-up travaillent justement
sur l'amélioration de l'offre du club et
en fait plutôt que de décaler le point
de vue par rapport au club et de sortir
du club elle proposait des solutions qui
justement font vivre le club de manière
différente et euh et de manière digitale
euh la première start-up sur ce sujet
c'est tout simplement sporty sport ay
ils ont créé un assistant coach euh pour
les clubs sportifs euh Albin et Nizar
qui ont créé cette cette société ils
étaient tous les deux entraîneurs d'une
équipe de foot entraîner une équipe de
foot c'est tout simplement avoir pour
avoir 22 joueurs le jour J le weekend 30
35 joueurs dans sa base de données quand
on joue en en loisir et envoyer un mail
à 33 personnes à attendre les 32 retours
des personnes qui viennent qui viennent
pas tenir c'est un travail de fou il
faut relancer le vendredi il faut
envoyer des textos bah donc ils ont tout
simplement créer une application qui
fait tout ça automatiquement et qui
permet de simplifier ce travail du coach
ça crée aussi du covoiturage ça crée
aussi une vie d'équipe beaucoup plus
simple et des start-ups qui aident des
associations sportives on en a d'autres
on a icotise qui permet aux associations
sportive de d'avoir une cotisation en
ligne et de plus avoir tous ces
problèmes de trésorerie et tous ces
problèmes de chèque perdus on a fusbered
qui permet du financement participatif
pour les associations sportives et donc
au final les start-ups qui sont censés
inventer le sport de demain elle
l'invente mais sans forcément bannir les
acteurs traditionnels du sport et ça
c'était une première leçon une première
leçon très importante ça nous a permis
de faire quelque chose de tout simple
c'est que six start-up du trempelin ont
été il y a maintenant 2 mois se
présenter devant le Congrès du CNOSF du
Comité national olympique et sportif
français devant plus de 100 présidents
de fédération et c'est une des forces
aussi de les avoir regroupé dans un
incubateur ça veut dire que maintenant
on est suffisamment fort pour dire à des
acteurs institutionnels majeurs du sport
écoutez-nous écoutez ce que les start-up
ont à vous dire pour ces start-up là se
présenter en une fois devant 100
présidents de fédération c'était
forcément une opportunité unique
d'avancer d'aller plus loin dans leur
projet on a bien conscience néanmoins
que l'avenir du sport ce n'est pas que
les association sportive aujourd'hui la
volonté de liberté dans le sport elle
est forte et donc il y a forcément une
un ation du sport une uérisation du club
du club sportif par les salles de sport
mais les salles de sport sont
elles-mêmes déjà uérisées pourquoi parce
que Jim lib start-up qui est incubé chez
nous également a fait un constat simple
76 % des gens qui s'abonnent à une salle
de sport ne renouvellent pas leur
abonnement 10 % des personnes qui
prennent cet abonnement annuel au salle
de sport n'y vont qu'une seule fois
aujourd'hui les gens ont envie de
d'agilité de pouvoir de mobilité et de
pouvoir choisir quand ils veulent
l'activité qu'ils veulent pratiquer non
pas d'être dépendant d'un abonnement et
et donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait bah
ils ont créé des passes des passes une
journée des passes 3 journées des passes
5 journées on a aussi des start-ups
aujourd'hui qui créent du coaching
sportif en ligne on peut réserver son
coach pour faire du coaching dans son
appartement pour faire du coach pour
avoir un coach dans un parc à côté c'est
des choses qui sont extrêmement
importantes et puis puisque la
problématique du du traitement des
déchets va être évoqué tout à l'heure on
a aussi une start-up qui a décidé que
plutôt que de ramasser les déchets qui
existaient ça sera inévitable mais on
pouvait aussi essayer de ne pas créer
ces déchets et sur les courses à pied on
a énormément de déchets tout simplement
parce que on passe devant le ravitau on
prend le verre d'eau on boit une gorgée
et on jette le verre d'eau c'est un
gâchi d'eau potable absolument
extraordinaire et c'est une
problématique plastique donc quoi il se
pqu ils ont créé une Bido une Bido
comestible et biodégradable ce qui fait
que quand on passe au ravito on mange sa
Bido et il n'y a aucun déchet lié à ça
ils ont pu la présenter au président de
la République grâce au tremplin qui l'a
goûté il y a pas longtemps ce qui est
forcément également une satisfaction
pour une
start-up puis pour parler d'un d'un
autre sujet un sujet que que vous
connaissez peut-être un peu mieux ici
puisque Boris pourau qui est le
fondateur de running heros vient de CAD
Marseille
euh une importance majeure aujourd'hui
dans le sport c'est la gamification la
gamification du sport c'est trouver
toujours des solutions pour motiver
davantage les gens et lui il a créé une
communité aujourd'hui qui fait plus de
250000 personnes sur une idée simple
vous soyez récompensé donc quel que soit
le divice quel que soit l'objet avec
lequel vous courrez c'est vos
performances seront enregistrés seront
diffusés sur sa plateforme et il vous
récompensera par des cadeaux en fonction
de l'amélioration de vos performances
quand on parle du sport gamifié on ne
peut pas ne pas évoquer la réalité
virtuelle qui arrive demain quand on
fera du sport dans dans votre dans votre
salle juste à côté ici bien bientôt et
ben on pourra être en fait en plein
milieu de l'Amazon ou du Mississippi et
du coup avoir la visite d'un espace
magnifique pendant pendant le sport et
également bien sûr de la
compétition alors il y a le futur du
sport qui se pratique qui est
extrêmement importante mais il y a aussi
le futur du sport qui se regarde dans
l'économie du sport il n'y a pas que la
pratique sportive il y a le sport
spectacle c'est aussi quelque chose
d'extrêmement
important dans le futur du sport qui se
regarde on a déjà tout simplement la
volonté euh de mettre de la data au
centre de tout ça si vous avez vu le
film Le Stratège le stratège c'est un
film qui montre comment la data est
apparue dans le sport de haut niveau un
club de baseball tout simplement n'avait
plus les moyens de rivaliser d'un point
de vue financier avec ses adversaires
ils ont décidé de changer les modalités
de recrutement de ne pas recruter en
fonction des avis des recruteurs
justement en en fonction des avis des
coaches mais uniquement en fonction des
datas uniquement en fonction des données
et comme beaucoup de sports américains
le baseball comp porte énormément de
données donc ils ont fait de l'analyse
ils ont fait des algorithmes ils ont
recruté une équipe qui a eu des
résultats inespérés l'année suivante
alors que tout le monde les voyait les
voyait perdant euh aujourd'hui on a de
plus en plus
de de de start-up qui travaillent sur
cette histoire sur ces histoires de de
Big Data il on a notamment mclyd qui est
une start-up française et qui fait ses
capteurs connectés que vous voyez
derrière l'omoplate des joueurs de rugby
euh faut faire attention dans le sport
de niveau avec la data il y a 2 ans pour
notre plus grand plaisir les Anglais ont
décidé de sortir ben JS leur dem000 mêlé
au tournoi destination 2014 parce que
sur l'iPad c'est courbe de commencer à
descendre sauf que à la 70e minute il
avait encore un impact déterminant sur
l'arbitre sur le match sur ses
coéquipiers les Anglais menaient plus de
10 points ils ont perdu à la fin du
match donc les datas c'est bien ça a des
limites aussi et c'est tout le travail
des start-ups d'être capable d'analyser
et d'interpréter ces données aujourd'hui
on sait que dans le sport de haut niveau
il y a de plus en plus d'exence
l'exigence c'est quand on est dans un
stade quand on vit l'expérience parce
qu'on veut la vivre on veut aussi avoir
la même qualité que à la télé donc on
veut un second écran l'importance des
stades et de ces nouveaux stades de plus
en plus performant c'est aussi la
rentabilité c'est pour ça qu'on est des
start-ups qui travaillent sur des
modèles de rentabilité de la billetterie
sportive avec des modèles de y de
management comme sur les billets de
train comme sur les billets d'avion et
puis on a
également on a parlé tout à l'heure de
réalité virtuelle c'est-à-dire de
s'immerger dans une réalité différente
on a aussi la réalité augmentée
c'està-dire on est devant sa télévision
d'avoir tout un tas d'informations
supplémentaires pour pouvoir analyser le
match et le vivre différemment nous le
trempelin quel est l'impact qu'on a eu
pour pour toutes ces sociétés euh on va
pas se mentir les stars les forces vives
c'est les start-ups c'est pas nous c'est
pas le travail que nous faisons
trempelin néanmoins on a eu un rôle
d'impulsion on a eu un rôle de
présentation auprès d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs et on est très fier parce que
on pense qu'on a contribué avec tout
tout simplement notre petite pierre
à développer l'innovation dans le sport
les quelques chiffres qu'on a au bout
d'un an d'existance ils sont simples ils
sont que les start-ups du Tremplin elles
ont créé plusieurs dizaines d'emplois
elles ont levé plusieurs elles ont levé
plusieurs millions d'euros et si on
avait un doute sur le fait qu'on les a
un petit peu aidé bah on a fait un
questionnaire anonyme et les 17 start-up
du trempelin de la première année
recommanderaient toutes à d'autres
start-up du sport d'intégrer le
trempelin donc on se dit qu'on a eu un
tout petit peu d'influence aussi sur
leur réussite et sur leur S sur leur
succès je vous
remercie